I really need the mean video of a Jets
fan talks to a Patriots fan where I
destroy that kid what time is it - 10 -
10 p.m.
team Gary off-site had the early this
morning had the people from vena
productions and the creative team and
the CFO come out here as well for an
off-site to get vaynermedia and vaina
productions aligned on how we produce
and all that stuff super excited about
that now here with 20 or so homies huge
huge missed by Babb and to start off he
was supposed to be filming the last four
hours of this we went around and kind of
got acquainted with each other with
updates started working on my kind of
texts CRM infrastructure did a lot of
awesome stuff lost now in history cuz
when I yell debate babban hey Pavan
weren't you supposed to be filming all
this his amazing reply was oh yeah
that's where we're at right now now
we're talking about the Gary B search
engine if you go to Gary V intercom
under askgaryvee there's a search engine
we're developing a 2.0 version on that
gonna look a Kastner andy the rest of
team so just some team bonding some
strategies around creative utility and
all the projects I'm working on whether
it's the case with the book the wine
club hip hop collaborations just really
focused this new search engine that you
guys have if you want to pull it up Andy
supposedly this is better than what we
had so put him put in snapchat yeah this
is [ __ ] awesome it's used like it's
using de vivir - yeah so hit so hit
keynotes hip keynotes just for a second
type into Instagram it should be a de
vivir that pulls up versus in a skater
oh you go on but you can nip my Dale you
be anyone saying all hit all and then I
want to see what thumbs up it's super
random but who cares that's super easy
we would go by most recent think it's
very debating the a scary the the Gary
Vee actual search engine transcribing as
some of you guys know on my website a
scary
tab on my West website you can search
any word and get get the information we
know this is valuable
we've got content on the podcast we've
got content on the YouTube channel we're
moving to askgaryvee on facebook only so
we're just debating and then debating if
it's even working right now internally I
think it's Kendall Irish or somebody
Justin can I get that I really need the
meme video of a Jets fan talks to a
Patriots fan right destroy that kid so I
I get to Boise I meet this kid Josh it's
nice to meet you in the airport man
later at the conference he asks this
question and he asked me an e at the end
tries to razz me he's like no I've not
watched the Patriots play a down of a
Super Bowl game in the last four Super
Bowls that they played in because I
refused everybody's like the greatest
comeback in a Super Bowl I'm good
I have no idea what the [ __ ] you guys
are talking about I didn't see [ __ ] so
while we hang out and I'll come and show
you what real winners you know you'll
get to see real winners play right
you're a Jets fan I'm a Patriots fan I'm
gonna show you how real winning looks or
something I go no no then up just you
Josh you confused my friends I'm a
winner
you root for winners dick
you can't maybe we should title it when
Jets fans actually beat Patriot fans or
something like so we gotta figure out
the right title
I want superphone like if we leave here
in a couple hours and nothing was
accomplished I'm gonna kill somebody
like superphone should be done I
actually do engagement like I'm just
like hitting up these people is this a
bot watch this camera okay reverse video
okay if my name is bot now it is our
view that guy's gonna [ __ ] and his taxis
getting that video ready hey guys it's
Gary Vaynerchuk dressed down and excited
for the first monthly wine club of
October first of all I want to start
with thanking everybody for subscribing
to the monthly wine club my big goal is
to create the most epic the coolest the
best wine club in the world and I hope
you enjoyed our first interaction
together if you want to join my monthly
wine club go to winelibrary.com and
search gary vee youtube right now i'm
recording for the Alexus skill for Wine
Library which is coming out soon so just
say start tasting to Alexa and let's
rock and roll
awesome what I want to do is I don't
want the bat I want them to like be
floating I don't want the mat so I got
it perfect perfect perfect sweet yeah
and then you'll show me a three two and
one yep what's the update so we're
trying to get a hot spot so we can go on
girl power and update although do we
have any actions did you get good audio
or was erotic you're gonna transcribe it
right okay okay I love it
so no I like everything you can keep it
from that part like I like where all you
have to do is when you when you make
that thing I want you to take over the
whole screen put it in green and just
green lettering and just like really
impact like good design and it like the
design right and just put like this is
where it turns episode 292 just wraps
getting in the comments Lander Hendrix
likes the editing
that's for you babban just trying to
build her self-esteem up
you like that what's up
Wow is that somebody I thought that was
subtle and you know what I might have to
only guys travel with me now I like the
last track this is the theme like
SeaWorld intergalactic mentions and he's
one of four people she or he is one of
four people that die on your own sword
part which I obviously was the focus of
this is so imperative like I'm glad to
see a lot of people understand where I'm
coming from and that like too many
people conforming and we're gonna end up
losing and that's like a double loss
you're just better off holding your your
conviction and if you lose at least you
only lost once a lot of people don't
realize they're on a path of oh and to
and and if I'm gonna lose I'd rather be
one in one right sorry
Pauline just living says the title
nailed it the description nailed it the
job copy teen comic devour amazing
observation in the workout video I yes
that is correct that is a bald bull Mike
Tyson's punch-out t-shirt good job I
like you characters in the comments
always given me a feedback as well
Michael your scope says d-roc did you
add it this one's very very good edited
job the answer to that is he sure did it
I love that people let's just keep it on
his face so have you that's enjoying it
Seth I don't think everything is funny
today handles handles on handles guys
it's Gary Vaynerchuk you are seeing this
video because I am announcing the
digital uncorked series by vaynermedia
having these off sites is important you
gotta break the patterns because rhythms
get everybody aligned get everybody
aligned on the same mission what are we
doing here I feel good about today so
far good way I feel like we're wrapping
up soon you know some people perform
better than others we know who they are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]